after two months of living under
lockdown the Scottish First Minister
announced the end is in sight I can
confirm that the government intends to
move from lockdown to phase one and
thereby lift some restrictions from the
twenty-eighth of me the plan comes more
than two weeks after the Prime Minister
announced the lifting of the lockdown in
the UK but the devolved administration's
refused to follow suit it may seem
fragmented or even confused but this is
the reality of devolution in the UK the
UK government just does not control
health policy or education policy in
Wales Northern Ireland's or here in
Scotland's what the pandemic has done is
laid bare the way different
administration's reacts in very
different ways the more cautious
Scottish approach has been broadly
welcomed by residents and contrasts
sharply with the speeds people in
England were urged back to work think
she's actually thought about the long
term like health statistics much better
than Boris has I think she's do lucky
compared to the First Minister's plan
for lifting Scotland's lockdown is
similar to much of what was announced by
Boris Johnson for the wall school
children will stay off for longer in
Scotland the main difference appears to
be the way she has communicated with the
public
she has been admirably clear and
forthright and candid through a lot of
this emergency and you know even some of
the people who vote conservative or
labour in Scotland are prepared to
concede that but in terms of actual
policy you know there's been very little
difference between Scotland England
politics as usual has been suspended
temporarily at the seat of power but
this unity is unlikely to hold and while
the coronavirus has encouraged the four
nations of the UK to work together
the next phase could hold more friction
I think as we move to the next phase as
we exit the lockdown as we move to
responding to the cases and rebuilding
the economy I think that's when we will
start to see more tensions more
difficulties emerging and perhaps more
ideological distinctions in the
approaches that
despite voting no in 2014
Scotland is currently split 50/50 on
independence and remains deeply divided
Scotland is set to head to the polls
next year in an election that could
prove consequential for the future of
the UK halima Hadean al Jazeera
Edinburgh